[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's
start with a quick view
of what's happened recently with
the Google Developer platform,
also known as the TLDR.
User identity has
gotten a lot easier
with the latest release
of Google Play Services.
We've revamped sign-in to
make implementations simpler
and provide users a more
streamlined experience.
Other updates, TouchSmart
Lock APIs, the Fused Location
Provider, and App Invites.
Magnus is on the show
today to tell us more.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
More than 19,000 organizations
are now testing or using
Android for Work, which
makes it easier and safer
for employees to use their
own Android devices for work.
Important bug and
crash fixes are
in place with the latest release
of the Android Support Library,
available now.
Find success with your app or
game business with Google Play.
This is the goal
behind a new playlist
of videos from our annual
developer event, Playtime 2015.
The Android Dev Summit is
just around the corner.
If you can't make it
in person, remember
to tune into the live
stream November 23 and 24.
Also, the Chrome Dev
Summit has wrapped.
And if you weren't able to
make it in person, that's OK.
All the sessions are
available online.
Splash screens for web apps
launched from the home screen
on Android, and script
execution deferring
are two big things launching
with Chrome 47 on December 1.
Pete is on the show
today to tell us
what we need to pay the most
attention to for that launch.
PETE LEPAGE:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Compound
bindings, as well as
affective children and
distributed node observers,
are the two significant
features included in the latest
release of Polymer.
The Google Maps API
meetups and hackathons
will continue with the Europe
version of Code the Road.
You can sign up
today to find out
what's possible with
the Google Maps API.
Follow the link to
this and everything
mentioned in the TLDR in
the description below.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
this is the developer show.
You've probably been wondering
what runtime permissions
on Android M mean for you.
Well, here's Reto to explain
it all in a segment we call,
who's doing what now?
MALE SPEAKER: I heard
Android 6 is out.
It's mostly what, just
kind of bunch of bug fixes?
MALE SPEAKER: Wait, are you
calling doze mode and runtime
permissions a
couple of bug fixes?
MALE SPEAKER: Uh.
I don't know, yes?
MALE SPEAKER: It's going
to be freakin huge.
MALE SPEAKER: Wait,
wait, wait, so hold on.
Who's doing what now?
RETO MEIER: Don't let
that happen to you.
I'm Reto Meier, and this
is Who's Doing What Now?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: What
is that about?
RETO MEIER: Until now, apps
have had to ask permission
for every device
feature that they
may need to use before
you've even installed it.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey Reto.
Before we can interact, I'd just
like you to sign a few things
that I may want to do.
So I'd like to
take your picture.
I'd also like to know your exact
location, your recent calls,
and of course, all
of your friends,
and their contact information.
So if you could just--
RETO MEIER: Hard pass.
This sort of approach
made a lot of sense
back when each app served
one specific purpose.
A camera app that wants
to take your photo.
A concierge app that wants
to know where you are,
or a replacement
dialer that needs
to know your contacts and
your most recent calls.
These days, apps have found
all sorts of innovative ways
to take advantage of many of the
sensitive features and sensors
on a device.
And users want to decide which
features to take advantage of,
and what information
they're willing to share.
When you target Android
6, API level 23,
you need to check every time
you perform an operation that
requires user permission, as
users can revoke permission
at any time.
If you don't have
permission yet,
you can request it,
optionally showing a rational
explaining why you need it.
This will ask the
user for permission,
which they can accept or deny.
And you can see the
results in this callback.
Of course, it's good
practice to fail gracefully
if permission is not
granted, and to only ask
of missions you really need.
Users potentially denying
dynamic runtime permissions--
that's who's doing what now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Google
Play Services 8.3
is out in the wild.
And on the show today to tell
us all about it is Magnus.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Hey.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's OK.
I asked Magnus to use his
indoor voice on the show today.
And there's no launcher.
It's dangerous in the studio.
But you know what, we can talk
about Google Play Services.
In fact, let me just count them.
There's four people
in the audience that
haven't seen your videos yet.
So if you could
just, in a nutshell,
what are Google Play Services?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Of course.
Google Play Services
is about 21 APIs that
sits over the Android platform.
So it contains things like
Google Map, Google Drive,
Google Fit, and the
Vision API for example.
And it's completely disconnected
from the Android releases.
So we can actually push
Google Play services out
to the external developer
audience five or six
times per year.
So that means we can create
a lot of information,
and get that available to
developers very, very quickly.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Now in 8.3, what's the
one thing that people
should pay attention to?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So
the one thing in 8.3
specifically is the sign-in API.
So the sign in API has been
completely refactored in 8.3.
Whereas previously, it
was tightly connected
to the Google API
client, it has now
been broken out and refactored
into a separate API.
And that means that you
can connect new APIs
and you can change the scope's
without having to reconnect
the entire Google API client.
That's managed completely
separately in the Google
sign-in API instead.
So that's a great new feature.
It allows developers to write
code which is a lot cleaner
and easier to read.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Great.
Google Play Services 8.3
Earlier today, I tracked down
the tech lead of TensorFlow
to get some more details about
machine learning, TensorFlow,
and how you can use
it in your apps.
So I managed to
track down Rajat.
He is on the Google Brain team.
And he's the TL for
TensorFlow Rajat, hello.
RAJAT MONGA: Hi.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
So TensorFlow is an open source
toolkit for machine learning.
Now I'm hoping that you can give
us a little bit more insight
for our developers out
there about machine learning
and why TensorFlow is so cool.
So let's start with
machine learning.
Give us, kind of in a
nutshell, for app developers--
not for researchers
or academics,
but for app developers--
what is machine learning?
RAJAT MONGA: So if you think
about how you might teach
a two-year-old what
different things are-- let's
say cats and dogs-- you would
show them pictures of cats,
and you would show
them pictures of dogs,
and tell them what each is.
And then over time, they'll
learn to recognize those
automatically.
Well, you can do the same
thing with computers as well.
And that's really what
machine learning helps with.
So for example, you could
have a million images,
and take those and sort of--
some of dogs, some of cats,
some of cows, and so on.
And once you train
a model with that,
the computer can
learn to recognize
what is cat, what is dog.
If you're showed it
new images, they'll
be able to tell what it is.
So images is one area.
But you can really use that to
make all kinds of applications
smarter, to help them
automatically pick up
the things that the user
wants, before the user having
to specify exactly what.
It's used in many,
many different products
that you're probably used to.
For example, the one I
like to talk about the most
is Google Photos.
If you go--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So cool.
RAJAT MONGA: It is.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Show
me photos of a bike.
And that's all my bike
photos, or whatever it is.
RAJAT MONGA: Exactly.
And this is the technology
being used there.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What's
the workflow from,
say, like idea to
it's in an app.
RAJAT MONGA: So if you
think about researchers,
what they like to do is,
they have new ideas that they
want to try out, maybe on their
data set and build a new model.
And what TensorFlow
allows them to do
is it's really flexible for
them to build their model
and specify it exactly as
they like, and train it.
And then once they're
done with that,
the app developer can
take the trained model,
use the same library,
same API, and deploy it
on servers, in the data
center, or in that application
on the mobile phone.
We aim to release
real working models
for a lot of those, where
we provide the model
specification that
somebody could
use to train on their data set.
And in some cases,
actually pre-trained
on data sets that are
available, for example
for images, that can really
be used by the developers.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you
for taking time out today.
And of course, thank you
for working on TensorFlow.
And that's a closer
look at TensorFlow.
Please, check it out and tell
us how you use it in your app.
Hey Pete, Chrome 47.
What are the two biggest things
we need to pay attention to?
PETE LEPAGE: Well, there's
always new stuff with Chrome.
The two biggest ones that
I'm most excited about
are splash screens and
request idle callback.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Wow,
that's a mouthful
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah,
tell me about it.
Some of these API names are--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: A lot of
letters in those identifiers.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
Splash screens for apps that
users have added to their home
screen provide a new,
dynamically generated splash
screen when they're launched.
In the past, if you launched an
app from the home screen, you
just--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You've
got the app loading
and it loads the
web page after that.
And it's just--
PETE LEPAGE: And
all the user saw
while all that stuff was
happening was a white screen.
It was boring.
It didn't look like an installed
app or anything like that.
Well now Chrome
will automatically,
dynamically generate
those splash screens
using the manifest file.
It looks for three things.
It looks for the app name, it
looks for a background color,
and it looks for a set of icons.
Now, the icons get
a little bit tricky
because, it's
looking for, ideally,
a 128 device pixel icon.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Device pixels--
PETE LEPAGE: Device pixel,
us web developers don't
do device pixels all that well.
So what you need to know,
the easiest way to do it,
is take the 128, make sure
you've got a 128 times 1.5
to give you the 1.5x
devices, times 2,
so 256 CSS pixels for the 2x
devices, times 3, and times 4.
And that will pretty much
cover all your devices.
And then, voila, you've
got a splash screen.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Great,
so splash screen.
What's the next one?
PETE LEPAGE: Request idle
call back essentially lets
you say, hey, I've
got JavaScript
that I need to run when
the system is in idle.
If you are running JavaScript
while the user is doing
something-- if
they're scrolling,
or while something else is going
on, you're going to get jank.
Request idle call back is
run when the device is not
doing anything.
So it's a really easy way
to say, hey, this is not
the most important JavaScript.
Let's go run this when
we've got some time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Very cool.
Chrome 47.
PETE LEPAGE: Chrome 47.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks Pete.
PETE LEPAGE: Out soon.
Thanks.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We're nearly at
the end of our show for today.
But I have one final
question for the panel.
Pete, what happens when
you break the build?
PETE LEPAGE: I've
never broken the build.
Web fundamentals has
always been perfect.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Magnus, what happens
when you break the build?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: When
I break the build,
I go like this--
I broke the build!
And then I work like crazy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, Dan Galpin
broke the build this week.
And this is what happened
when he tried to fix it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And that was Tuesday.
Hey, you know what?
I can't get everyone
here on the show,
but I can ambush
them at their desk.
Have a question about
a Google platform,
or anything really, let
me know in the comments,
and I'll track them down
with my selfie stick.
Thanks for joining us here
on the developer show.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]